[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
I'll be bolder than Blair on public
reform The Observer quotes labor leader
sakir starmer for its headline
the Sunday Express is focused on the
coronation with the headline King's
solemn vow to serve us all
also focused on the coronation the mail
on Sunday front cover reads we are all
invited to swear our allegiance to the
king
while the Sunday Mirror focuses on the
cost to taxpayers with their coronation
front story with the headline 150
million pounds on security hikes up the
coronation bill
and the sun turns to the movements of
Prince Harry saying he only plans a
Whistle Stop visit during the coronation
weekend their headline Harry in a hurry
the front of the Sunday Telegraph quotes
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis in their
headline which reads I support badanoc
in her war on wokery
the star on Sunday has an exclusive on
the cancer battle fought by Comedian
Bobby davro's fiancee
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by the
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons welcome to
you both well let's start with the
Sunday Express and the coronation uh
just a few days now before the actual
ceremony and the Kings solemn vow to
serve us all this is in Breaking with
tradition Christina
yes I mean I think it's part of
um the king's
desire to be
very kind of um
inclusive with this ceremony there are
going to be representatives from all
faiths I think for the first time ever
the Archbishop of country is going to
refer to all faith in the ceremony it's
going to be
um very I think we've seen from some of
the guests who are invited to take part
in the ceremony that it's going to be
much much more uh multi-faith and
multiracial than a previous coronations
um I think I I must say that I mean the
idea is that formerly apparently the
aristocracy vowed their allegiance to
um the new monarch and I can understand
why that would seem rather anachronistic
and weird today and therefore that it
has been opened up to anyone sitting on
a sofa anywhere who wants to vow their
allegiance to the Monarch I have to say
it feels like rather a strange idea to
me I can't quite imagine sitting there
you know eating a packet of Doritos and
swearing allegiance to King Charles it
does all feel a bit medieval and I I
think that's my feeling about the whole
thing I think I think King Charles is
going to be a very good King I think
that he you know he cares about the
right things he was way ahead of his
time on the environment on a
multiculturalism on support for inner
city communities and inner city
youngsters I think in many ways he's a
good thing but it is quite a weird thing
uh to have a monarch who is even if they
are just sort of technically a head of
state the fact that this is such a kind
of solemn ceremony where he gets
Anointed with oil and you know there is
an oath of Allegiance it does seem a bit
strange to me I have to admit Jake what
what are your views well will you be
pledging that oath of Allegiance uh
sitting at home on the sofa
certainly I I think that I mean this
this week
um lots more details are being released
um slowly but surely about the
innovations that the coronation is going
to see this time around and as Christina
said there are two main areas it says
Innovations are taking place one in in
terms of opening the ceremony up to
being more uh inclusive of different
faiths uh and women as well there are
some women clergy who are playing
prominent roles in a way that hasn't
happened before
um and also it's including other
languages like
um Gaelic Welsh uh Scottish Gaelic and
Irish Gaelic and Welsh as well so the
king's obviously making a a big effort
to include everybody uh in the country
in the coronation in some way but the
other Innovation is to take the focus a
little bit more away from the
aristocracy as Christina mentioned
um and plays it more towards the common
people in the country if you like
um and the main way in which this is
happening is that the hereditary peers
who formerly went first to pledge
allegiance to the king
um and then touched the crown and kissed
his right cheek and now not playing that
role and instead this great Pledge of
Allegiance is taking place around the
country and around the world virtually I
suppose if you like uh people in there
in their uh in their sitting rooms
speaking to the screen
um and this is an extension of the
Innovation that he announced a couple of
weeks ago that the hereditary peers are
not going to be wearing their robes
which is a 500 year old tradition which
he's getting rid of and I think the
sense is that during the cost of living
crisis there's a there's a wish to to
hold back the the lavishness in some way
of the coronation and personally I feel
a little bit less comfortable with that
idea I feel like you know it's a bit
late to hold back on the lavishness of
the correlation because it's very lavish
that's the whole point of it I don't
think that will make much difference and
it feels a bit of a shame to me to lose
the tradition of of of the robes and the
ceremony that have been around for so
many centuries uh Christina what do you
think on that point because it isn't as
lavish as it could have been because the
King has wanted a pair down
um service but but there there are I
mean some of one of the papers is
actually looking at the the course
that's the mirror 150 million on
Coronation security
um and their estimates that it could
exceed that cost
yeah I mean I I think it would take a
real Grouch to sit around and moan about
the cost of a coronation when there
hasn't been one for 70 years
um or you know more than 70 years I
think look I mean correlations are
expensive but they don't happen very
often if we imagine if we had an
enormous ceremony every time we change
prime ministers in the country in this
country I mean we've been you know
wrecking through them at a rate of of
not uh so you know I don't begrudge
anything spent on discurination in terms
of global focus and media coverage and
tourism actually it will I'm sure earn
whatever is spent it will uh give us a
return on investment as the business
people like to say I don't share Jake's
worry about the robes I I really don't I
mean I think the peerage is a very
outdated concept and I absolutely
support King Charles who has kind of you
know through no desire of his own ended
up as in this peculiar position of being
King of a country who you know I think
probably in lots of ways doesn't really
believe in an aristocracy and he's doing
his best to make this peculiar
institution as modern as it can be in
the circumstances and I wish him the
very very best of luck with it the
mirror is saying that the total spend is
set to reach a 250 million and there are
those Jake who say in the midst of a
cost of living crisis where when people
are struggling to pay for food to eat
during the colder months that to heat
their homes that this is quite vulgar
yeah like I can I can relate to that and
I think that everybody
um you know almost everybody in the
country is is feeling the pinch and has
been over the last year increasingly so
um and the timing isn't brilliant to
have such a big uh and lavish display of
uh of wealth and Prestige and and
hierarchy
um but at the same time the coronation
will give everybody a lift as Christina
mentioned it doesn't happen very often
and it would be a shame I think to do it
um in a sort of half-hearted way I feel
like what if it's if it's happening it's
happening you've got to go big or go
home with it I think on the whole the
British public will very much get behind
it uh we we need these focuses in our
national life of of togetherness and
identity and optimism
um and the King has has been exemplary
really so far in uh in reaching out to
people in including
um all faiths and all people
um in the Embrace of the coronation and
I think he said setting a very good
precedence and a very good example and I
think it will do wonders overall for our
public mood although it is a slightly
eye-watering bill at the end of it
yes uh Christina the mail talking about
um the pledge to Allegiance that's uh
being asked of all of us the homage of
the people at just one of the
significant updates to the ancient
ritual and see other religious faiths as
well as the Church of England and that's
something that we know is close to the
king's heart when he was Prince Charles
he wanted to be defender of the Fates
um plural and that was something that he
was very keen to do and and this
coronation does seem to embrace other
faiths we'll have Rishi sunak um reading
from the Bible
absolutely and I think I think I mean
this is not you know nobody could accuse
King Charles of wokery because he has
taken this position very very strongly
for decades and uh you know his work
with the princess trust for example
which was you know way ahead of so many
charities in in uh giving opportunities
for inner city youngsters and uh of you
know many backgrounds cultures and
faiths and I do think I mean one of the
unfortunately for those of us who who
you know don't support brexit which is
now the majority of the British
population I think according to recent
polls more than 60 more than 60 percent
of people think brexit was a mistake it
doesn't seem like this these don't seem
like high Glory Days but I do think that
in in King Charles I think he is someone
who's been very very forward thinking
and I think one thing we can be
relatively proud of in the UK is that
relatively speaking we are successful
Multicultural multiracial country
obviously there is enormous racism in
every country and you know there is not
uh equality of opportunity and uh you
know I'm sure that nobody would say this
is any kind of Utopia but so clearly
isn't but I do think that compared to
many world cities we are and London for
example is doing better than most and
compared to many countries we do better
than most on this front and I think to
have a monarch who is actively seen and
as he has done all his life to support
different perspectives different faiths
different cultures I think that is a
real asset to the United Kingdom and
Jake do you think the Mel's right in its
prediction that this will be come known
as the the people's coronation
it might do I mean certainly this is a
big step there's a big innovation I mean
by comparison to the last coronation
um the the technology didn't exist to
allow everybody to get involved
simultaneously in this way
um and so it is a big step and I do hope
that it will bring people together and
the people will get involved and it will
ignite that sense of uh patriotism and
National togetherness which has been so
damaged in in recent in recent years
um and as Christina was saying it it's
very welcome that the king is including
all faiths in the coronation
um as editor of the Jewish Chronicle
obviously I I welcome that but I I'm
also I also welcome the fact that the
Archbishop of Canterbury did say that
the the ceremony must have a Christian
center of gravity or or worse for that
effect you know this is a Christian
country and the coronation must reflect
um that that sense and that character
and it's the position of other things to
be included but to respect that
overarching culture and I think that on
the whole
um it will do that and it will be very
harmonious and uh and and good tempered
and we'll bring people together which is
which is really all we can hope for yes
and one of those people are traveling
for the coronation is uh Prince Harry
but uh the son's saying that it's just
going to be a Whistle Stop visit
Christina
yeah I mean I don't think anybody is
surprised by that I think that um it was
always bound to be short and it is his
son's birthday
um I think either that day or the next
day so whether or I mean he has an
excellent excuse for dashing back but I
can't imagine he was very inclined to
hang around for a long time anyway the
most important thing is that he's coming
after all the Heartbreak that has been
caused in the last couple of years with
the the Memoir and the Oprah Winfrey
interview and all kinds of other things
I think it's really important that Harry
will be there supporting his father at
his coronation and I hope that that can
begin to heal some of the Rifts that
have been caused in the family